for two years julie shielded from the
world
she has a muscle wasting disease
and is clinically vulnerable
but now
covid has found her
um
well i had to call that symptoms at home
you know a lot of coughing and things
and
then i went up like i painted
and then
that one came into office so you could
get a little bit worse way
just to breathe inside a little bit
julie's doctors say she's alive because
she's been vaccinated
but not all of the royal preston
hospitals 125
covet patients are
the variants driving this summer surge
might not be making patients as
seriously ill but these variants are
more transmissible and with every
patient who ends up in hospital well
that's more pressure
all the way through the system
for dr mohamed
it means another one of his beds is
taken that means each of those areas
other patients cannot be admitted and
treated and patients have been waiting
for a long time already so their
procedures their
treatment is once again getting delayed
that is putting a lot of pressure on the
system and on the restorative work which
has started very well
here in the northwest they've seen a
rise of between 50 to 200 percent in
coveted infections in recent weeks she's
coming
around 500 of the hospital staff are off
sick with covert related absences
and this at a time when the hospital's
emergency department is struggling to
cope with a sheer number of patients
coming through its doors
summer or winter
the pressure is relentless
for the past two years we've always
thought it can't get any worse
and then it does and each time we think
it's as bad as it possibly could be
there's something else that comes along
on top of it
what we found at the moment with a
combination of factors coming through is
that we're just having to work harder
and harder and harder
every wave brings pressure even mild
covered has consequences
these things happen and you think
should we really be
you know this kind of relaxation
about it really
i'm not sure i don't know
the government says
we must all move on
but this
is what living with covid
means to julie
ashish josh is sky news in preston